the Joe Rogan experience show the
difference is that how many people are
fans and how many people just flip with
your channel there's nothing else so on
yeah I've seen I've seen episodes of you
I've watched a bet you have I definitely
have like when when normals are Suzy
would normally would Donald Trump the
hands-on was that that was the best
episode of normal is norm at one point
says I've never had consensual sex with
a woman he just got tripped up in his
words he news on this apology tour and
he was like it was it was right as that
said this is the stage his it's right as
his Netflix show is about to air and he
gets in big trouble he because he's on
stir no no no homo started over he he
defends Louis first okay and then Ament
and lows Roseanne then he goes on Stern
and when he's Stern and when he's
monitoring instead of saying like like
you'd have to be [ __ ] it's a likely
to laugh at this or to think this he'd
be like you'd have to have down syndrome
thank you saying that's better because I
think down syndrome was okay to say but
Robert is bad cuz it's night so he's a
bunch know and they're about to launch
the show so of course like you know
everybody involved is like panicking
like Leo you have a new show launching
you got it you got it so he goes on the
view and he's like yeah it's like yeah
and he is I'm like you can see you can
mute this and watch this
he is eating mints like as you had
popping them in his mouth eating man
shaking shaking his hand he's like
consensual sex with a girl consensual
sex with the girl egos why would I and
they're like no but I think you miss
being normal
you see you seem like you're on daytime
he's like he's like this oh I feel real
bad about that
he's [ __ ] wild man I was just talking
to Adam about this do you remember the
time you came we can't tell the full
story cuz I think a normally comforter
with it but do you remember the time
right before the election where you had
a vape pen that was really strong and
norm came back yes it was it was the
funniest [ __ ] up he was not ready
right before this yeah well guys like
that don't smoke weed a lot they just do
it occasionally I think they remember
what weed is right this way that they're
[ __ ] with today is a different animal
yes it's two in the pen so innocuous
it's just vaporizing English yeah but it
was it was hash oil in a pan it was
[ __ ] it was nuclear job I smoked with
him one time in a parking lot in Irvine
right before I was with Ryan Sickler
Ryan always has good weed Aaron and we
met norm and we were about to go in and
he smoked dude he's like such a
comfortable comic like with any like you
know he doesn't need like handing some
time alone to get my mind right before
this that were in the parking lot he
takes a [ __ ] monster hit of strong
wheat and he starts coughing like
coughing and ultimately you know like a
tear come really cool and then we walk
into the Irvine improv and they're
announcing him he just walks onstage and
he just starts talking about the soda
he's drinking and killing with it like
just off the top of his head just
totally not look comfortable he's one of
the funniest guys ever hit stand-up
changed the way I did this next special
though this next special was like bit
like because I love those guys that grow
you know that when you see them it's not
they're not doing they're like there's
nothing wrong with it but they're doing
the exact same type of
they didn't last one they're just
changing the names a little bit right
you know it's an and I looked at I
called Stanhope maybe one of the most
mind-bending days of stands that just
when you said that smell thing where
your brain goes wait what the [ __ ]
I called Stanhope one day and it was
like hey what you doing he's like
drinking a vodka grape suit trying to
grape grape juice grapefruit juice
trying to write a knock-knock joke I was
like what here's again I'm thinking of
funnies goofs you know trying to write a
knock-knock joke we got to be as funny
as those guys right I was like yeah and
he goes so we could write one couldn't
we here's the guy let me tell you what I
got
he's like reads a couple knock-knock
jokes and I was like yeah why the [ __ ]
aren't we [ __ ] with the format and
then norm
I seen norman norm has the best joke I'm
gonna tell you the joke is that great
it's the best is he still doing it no no
norm there's this this for me was like
this was like why aren't we going why
aren't we why aren't we sometimes taking
a step back to take a step forward right
norm has a joke he goes I got I got in a
neighbor I see the neighbor and I said
hey neighbor
what do you do for a living neighbor
says Nora I'm a professor of logic down
at the university there's science and
norm says what's that he goes well norm
it's hard for me explain it's easier to
me just show you what I do norm do you
have a dog house and I'm goes I do and
you know something you must have a dog
logically he goes I do have a dog and he
goes alright and if you have dog logic i
can assume you must have a child you
have a child norm and he goes I do have
a child as well if you have a child
logically I can assume you must be
married to a woman are you married to a
woman Norman he goes I am
who's norm then logically I could assume
you're a straight white male enormous
wow that's amazing
so the next day norms down on the bus
stop and having a cigarette sees another
one of his neighbors and neighbors
because norm do you meet the new
neighbor he goes yeah it did here's
what's he do for a living because he's a
professor of logic times the university
of science here's what is that because
well it's hard for me to explain there's
much easier for me because the Annie
goes yeah norm goes hey T up a doghouse
he goes no and he goes well you must be
a [ __ ]
why what like like burrito it's a great
joke why are we like we're all funny
like why can't because that's a
problematic word and it's banned one of
the great joke it's a great joke but
like those that old joke writing we all
stepped away from but like what if we
could tether ourselves to it at a bit
and what we're doing now normally does
that mark normative so Norman does but
like stand up going I'm right and
knock-knock jokes just for like a
writing exercise and where you go what
if you what if you just wrote like a
banger knock-knock joke
[Applause]